a good set of people here
and as as before
uh if you want to uh if you are
right now listed as an attendee and you
would like to
be able to unmute yourself and ask
questions just raise your zoom hand and
you can
uh you can be
promoted to a panelist and
yeah it would be great if more people
ask questions
more people turn on the cameras so and
please
feel welcome to to do it and uh
with that
and and with that let's say
um yeah let's start you should talk
about three of
uh of this three-part series thank you
uh so first of all thank you boz and the
organizers for
making this wonderful program so let me
now jump straight into
where we left from so from rachel stock
and
amit stock both of them did a wonderful
job at
motivating that in order to build
obfuscation it just suffices to build
a seemingly much simpler cryptographic
primitive that is
um a weakly secure structured seed prg
which i'm going to just focus on for
this talk and tell you how we can
construct it from prg's in nc 0 and lpn
and what's nice about just focusing on
this standalone problem is that
even if you missed the previous two
talks
and if you're just tuning right now if
you just believe me for the time being
that
in order to build i o it suffices to
just focus on this object
then hopefully the rest of the stock
should be understandable
and throughout this talk i'm just going
to use combinatorial and elementary
ideas
so i'm not going to assume too much of a
crypto background
and if there are any questions just
interrupt and ask
so let me start off by recalling uh
one of the the two main assumptions the
learning parity with noise which is just
just going to be a very brief recall
because we saw this in detail in our mid
stock and we are
also going to hear about it uh in
benny's talk so
just from the sake of setting up
notations uh
what does learning parity with noise
assumption says it says that
there are two distributions that are
indistinguishable in the first
distribution
i'm going to have noisy linear equations
now how are they sampled
so there's a field zp and um
and i'm going to sample n vectors so n
is polynomial in l
uh n vectors at random from z p to the l
uh and i'm going to denote by a i then
i'm sampling a secret s
at random from z p to the l again then
i'm going to compute these inner
products a i and s
and then i'm going to perturb these
inner products with a sparse noise
now how is this noise chosen is going to
be 0 with a
large probability so it's really sparse
however with tiny probability that is l
to the minus delta where l is the
dimension and delta is some fixed
constant
fixed once and for all between zero and
one and
with that probability i'm going to
choose it at random and then i'm going
to put a perturb with that noise
so then i have these noisy line
equations and i hand it out to this
adversary and this lpn assumption says
that
ai ais plus ci this distribution looks
computationally indistinguishable to ai
comma uniform
okay so that's the variant we are using
and as you can see
when delta increases becomes closer to
one this problem becomes easier and
easier
when delta is uh closer to zero this
problems becomes harder and harder
uh and just for the sake of concreteness
we are going to work
with delta which is an arbitrarily small
constant so even if this assumption
holds for delta equal to 0.0001
that's already enough for us to uh get
to i
so that's our first assumption uh the
second assumption we are making is
existence of
um boolean prgs in nc 0. i'm sure all of
you know what pids are they are length
expanding boolean functions
uh they take n bits as input and then
they output m bits
really think of m as some polynomial in
n so n to the one plus constant
we are looking for prgs evaluated by
constant depth boolean circuits
so nc 0 and this
has this traditional conventional notion
of security
that you hear in cryptography the notion
of pseudorandomness
what does it says it says that when x is
chosen at random
uh from 0 1 to the n then the output g
of x
should look computationally
indistinguishable to a random string of
length m
so that's your security and this is uh
prg's and nc 0 this has been reasonably
well studied there has been 20 years of
work
uh but that's not my job for today i'm
going to let
benny discuss history about it benny is
an expert on
prg's in nc 0. so i'm going to let him
speak about that
um i'm going to just tell you about two
facts which i'm going to use in the
construction so these
facts are kind of somewhat important so
i'll demand your attention here
um when i talk about any nc 0 function
and therefore
any prg and c 0 it has a constant
locality what do i mean by that i mean
that
if i look at the output which is an m
bit string every output bit is going to
depend on
at most a constant number of input bits
so that's just the fact of locality
being constant
and immediate fallout of stat is that
you can write
every output bit y i as some constant
degree multivariate polynomial over the
reals
treating input as the variables and in
fact this polynomial has integer
coefficients
okay so this is just an immediate
follow-up fallout of that
and i'm going to use this fact later on
this talk so
if you have any questions about that
just please feel free to ask me
um and just to give you a sense of what
parameters we are using
we are going to work with the prg with a
stretch of n to the one plus tau so m is
exactly n to the one plus tau
where tau is an arbitrary small constant
greater than zero so even if this
assumption holds uh
meaning that there exists a pr gene and
c zero with the stretch of uh
n to the one point zero zero one that's
already enough
so with that in mind with all these
definitions uh
in mind let's just get straight to
business uh
why are you sorry can i ask quick quick
question sure
um is there a connection between the
constant here and the
epsilon delta that we heard about from
the from the
lpn assumption i mean uh are they all
three constants uh or do they need to be
related in some way
they're all free they're they don't
uh depend on each other like you can
yeah okay so
um what is a structured heat prg uh we
have seen this definition
informally in rachel stock almost
formally in regional stock and uh
and in a mid stock uh so then let let's
dive deep into this
in here with formal definition roughly
there are prgs which are computable by
bilingual maps so they are bilinear map
frontier and this definition
is implicit in fact in previous works uh
however it's just formalized in this
current work what does it say so we are
really asking for a prg
which has a structured seed which has a
special structure
now in a traditional prg you would think
of the seed or the input being a random
string
over the hypercube here you are asking
that the seed is kind of fragmented like
there are two components in the seed
which i'll denote as the public part of
the seed and the secret part of the seed
so the public part of the seed is
actually just leaked out to the
adversary it's given in the clear
secret part of the seed is hidden and
what we demand is that think of these
seeds public and secret as being vectors
over z
p so p is looking ahead and connecting
the dot
is the order of the bilinear map that
we're going to use so you're asking for
these seeds to live in gp to decay
um they might be arbitrary correlated
there is no restriction on that they
might be
arbitrarily structured they don't have
to be uniform
and all that only thing is that they are
efficiently sampleable by some
polynomial time algorithm
okay now this is uh how the seed looks
like
and when it comes to output you're
asking that each output bit
um can be written as some constant
degree polynomial
on the public part of the seed and the
secret part of the seed with the
restriction
that it's just degree two over the
secret part of the seed mod p
so this polynomial is a word zp uh so
it's
the fact that it's a degree two over the
secret part of the seat roughly it's
coming from the fact that we are
going to use bilinear maps and remember
bilinear map only let you do
um up to a degree two computation over
the secrets
so that's the restriction where it's
coming from
and then we are asking some standard
uh properties first property is the
stretch the out
the number of output bits they should be
much more than in fact
some small polynomial in the size of the
public part of the seed plus secret
privacy so the total
seed length so that's just an extension
of
the expansion requirement of a regular
prg
now security is also a straightforward
generalization of a regular prg just
adaptation you're also going to leak the
public part of the seat
so given that the output y should appear
pseudorandom so p comma y should be
computationally indistinguishable to p
comma random string of length m
that's also a straightforward
generalization of regular prg definition
so that's what uh i hope the goal is
clear what are we trying to build and if
there are questions please interrupt me
right now
okay okay i'll assume that there are no
questions so
um that's what we are trying to build
now a reasonable question that
you might ask uh is uh why are we
considering this uh model at all
uh did it not suffice to just think of
prgs which are just degree two functions
over a
single secret seed and uh why was this
introduction of public seed necessary
um well it turns out turns out that's
what we considered we considered prg's
there's just wages
one seed and the output was a degree two
polynomial
um in a number of works we considered it
and unfortunately what happened is that
all of those proposals were
uh broken down in a series of
devastating attacks
so there was this really a nice line of
work by barack at all lombardi and veku
nathan and barack at all again
which showed um implausibility results
uh there are implausibility results
because they don't rule out
all generality of parameters and
candidates they just
do it enough so that they are shake our
confidence is like shaken in this whole
paradigm and what they used different
ideas but the unifying feature in all
these works
was that they relied on a really
powerful
hierarchy of convex optimization known
as the sum of squares hierarchy and if
you're aware
sum of squares is known to yield some of
the best known approximation
algorithm for some really hard problems
including the max cut problem
so all of them rely on sum of squares
unfortunately i won't
speak about it too much in the interest
of time the only thing i would
say that the take away from all this was
that you want to avoid
um using prgs which are just degree two
computations
that's what you want to avoid and i
remember when these all these attacks
came out
uh this was really disappointing in the
sense that this is another paradigm
which was broken down
uh over the past like you know quick
such section of time
uh and there was a general pessimism the
when this happened
however still we are really really
thankful that this happened because
because this kind of forced us to
consider this new model of this public
seat
there was no other choice we had to
consider a prg where there's this
extension
that we are considering so yeah we're
really thankful to all the people who
worked on it
and some of squares in general so thank
you for doing that
i would have loved to talk more about it
but unfortunately i can so
i'm happy to talk about it offline um i
have a doubt
so since in the security game you are
giving p in the clear
it's not completely clear to me how this
is really different from degree to
computation
i mean i don't know if this was
discussed already uh this was discussed
in regional stock but that's fine
uh could you repeat that yeah yeah i can
repeat the argument
so the the point is this um so you're
asking
essentially uh if you could sample this
p
uniformly and fix it in the crs right is
that what you're asking
yeah yeah yeah yeah but the point is
that
the the secret part of the seed will
actually depend on this fabric part of
the seed like there will be
correlation and if you just give it out
in crs then it's actually useless
you're not uh so you're saying uh the
key
snp it's not necessarily the pns are
chosen
independent of one another they are not
independent in fact that's that's very
crucial they are correlated in some way
in computationally hidden way so if
someone just looks at p they
they they won't be able to tell them
what's this the secret s but
but there's like some computationally
hard correlation between them which is
chosen as sampling so this is still a
stronger requirement right because you
are saying the led feeling something
about s in the form of p
and still it shouldn't be able it
shouldn't and you should be able to
come up with the secret yes that's
exactly what you're saying
okay okay thank you
okay so let's proceed now what's the
goal
how do we construct this so i hope
you're convinced that this considering
this model was somewhat necessary
so now let's see how you construe how
can how can you construct it so what's
the goal
ideally if everything worked out for us
beautifully
we would have wanted our input to sit in
a boolean hypercube like a random
input and the output should look like a
nice evaluation like prg and c0 g
evaluated at
sigma which is like an n to the one plus
tau bit output that's what you have
i really wanted but what's the problem
the problem is
that we do not know a prg in degree 2. i
mean all these attacks in fact point
otherwise
so this is not a degree to computation
we have to go at least degree 3.
so this you cannot do but what we
realized is that if you
are willing to use this model i'm going
to set this public seed very
cleverly i'm going to see set this
public part of the seed
as some lpn samples
encrypting the input sigma so let's see
how they are sampled
this is somewhat important so i i need
your attention here
so if you're if your input was n bits
i'm going to generate n samples how are
they sampled
well there are coefficient vectors a i
which are chosen from z p to the l
uh then there's a secret test which is
chosen from zp to the l so i'm
going to compute this a i and s then i'm
going to choose an error
this is chosen according to an lpn error
distribution so it's a sparse error
so it's non-zero only with the
probability l2k minus delta
then i'm going to add it and then add
use this lpn sample to encrypt sigma so
just add sigma into this so there are
n lpn samples encrypting sigma so that's
how we compute this public seat
the point if if we are willing to give
out these public public information
then i can come up with a really short
seed not really short but somewhat short
uh um seed private seed s and this
private seed is going to only depend on
two things so it's going to depend on
the
secret uh s so remember our secret
of the lpn is much more smaller than the
number of samples
so it's going to depend on that and then
it's also going to
it's also it's also going to depend on
the sparse error vector e
okay so i compute some information i'm
going to tell you exactly how we
what this is but just assume that it is
short such that the size of public seed
plus size of the secret seed is much
more smaller than m
uh and then what it lets you do
magically what we show in this work is
that you can
write each output bit of the prg as some
constant degree polynomial over pns
ah with the restriction that it's just
degree 2 over the secret
okay the exact complexity model that we
require
okay so once we have this and let's say
we are also able to argue security then
as rachel said
we are golden because we can uh get i o
using the same bootstrapping so only
thing i need to
tell you about now is how do i um what
are
like how do i evaluate it and what's the
security
turns out security is an embarrassingly
simple argument
um so amit talked about it in
his talk so therefore i won't spend too
much time if time permits i'll give you
formally but roughly the main idea is
that all adversely gets to see
is the prg evaluated at sigma and these
lpn samples encrypting
sigma remember these are lpn samples
which encrypt sigma so they are hiding
the seed sigma and then since the sigma
is hidden then g
of sigma appears to derive that's the
whole argument
uh so that's the security proof so more
interesting piece that remains is that
how does our private seed looks look
like and how we actually evaluate it
using constant degree point number
so i hope the goal is clear so uh if
there are questions please let me know
so um just to make sure that so
um what's the
uh so so i'm just a little bit confused
on uh
what do we think of sigma do we think of
it as a
a part of the private seed or a not part
of the private seed
no it won't uh the private seat will
just be a function of s
actually it will uh depend on sigma but
only like implicitly
uh so yeah i mean it will depend
but i'm going to tell you exactly how it
depends the type
in general private seed is allowed to
depend on everything
uh all randomness that you use to sample
pee
i see okay so ah okay okay okay so so
the private
so so uh okay so we are not directly
operating on sigma but rather we are
going to produce the output that we
we are going to produce the output that
we see on the right hand side by doing
some calculation
that will be only degree
degree to in the in s and a constant
degree
in capital p right exactly right but but
only restriction we want is that the
sampling algorithm has to be efficiently
efficient uh least sampleable private
seed and the public seed but
otherwise this private seat can depend
in any crazy fashion on all the
randomness used to sample
policy and again just to get kind of a
sense uh
s e right now uh much much smaller could
put
okay so maybe e naught so s at least
could be much much smaller than
uh potentially than uh than than m a
it could be it could be a small power of
m right yeah it's a it's in fact much
smaller than n
which is the number of samples or the
number of inputs but e
is uh not smaller than n but
sorry the e is a sparse vector so
it will also be like l to the minus
delta fraction of the total length of s
i see and this is that's crucial a
little bit about encoding
at some point yeah and then that's what
i'm going to talk about next
okay so just so you still didn't tell us
why you need the sparsity right
yeah and i haven't i'm just giving you
the conclusion that yeah okay this is uh
okay
sure so so maybe i missed it but
i'm not sure that i fully understand the
syntax of of this object
like the way that i understand it right
now maybe there's a different way to to
define it
you have a sampling like a sampling
algorithm that samples the output
but it also samples basically the the
the private seed like i don't know like
like some cause some sort of alternative
seed in a
in a public part such that given these
things
like this is kind of the processing
giving the things you can compute the
public output in a degree two thing
we had agreed to mapping that's the way
to think about it
yeah exactly so uh you have a desired
output g of sigma which is uh
which is what you want to compute now
there is a
algorithm that will run in uh so let's
say the running time of
uh that is like the length of the prg's
m
in a traditional prg you would think of
seed sampling algorithm
the should be much like independent of m
in this case however
um the seed sampling algorithm can take
time which is proportional to m like
crazy polynomial amount of time which
kind of compresses
this output in this way like it's going
to encode
the seed of the prg using this lpn
samples and then come up with this
preprocessing which
computing this preprocessing actually
takes a lot of time i'm going but
the only restriction is that it's short
that's the only restriction
we need so it's not the case that you
can generate the seed
do this kind of degree to like a random
seed apply a degree two and a half
computation on it and generate the
output this is not the case right
because
this is also related to a question
before yeah exactly the private part of
the state will depend on g
of sigma okay
sorry the private part of the seed ah
the private part of the seed will depend
on your sigma ah okay it will
okay so i didn't under get that okay so
basically
uh yes so so so there are two ways to uh
there are two ways to compute the output
one
is the way you actually use which
basically
you sample at random sigma e and s
and then obviously you can you can
compute everything that is on the right
box
and then there is an extra hypothetical
way which is
if you found some magical way to sample
uh g of sigma a capital p
and the pre-processing thing then uh
you can evaluate the
okay so if you found yours so yeah
you're right
technically i should have said it as
like pre-processing of s
e g of sigma and sigma basically
everything
okay well just sigma maybe okay or c
sure yeah our sigma
okay okay so maybe maybe i mean okay so
then maybe in person
in principle you could decide you could
compute you could ignore the obvious way
to compute you so one way to think about
it is
pre-processing is also a function of
sigma and what you do is
you sample a sample at random jointly
a capital s and capital p and then there
is a way
uh to uh to to compute
g er according to a formula is written
below right
yeah and we're going to do it in this
the only error really in the in this
slide is that the
pre-processing is really also of sigma
yeah it depends on all the randomness uh
used to sample p and desired output
so the pre-processing is basically
giving the key the secret key
right depends on the secret key
but it uh it it pre-possesses it in a
way
that will uh will allow you to
to only do degree to computation so
right so so it it it represents the
secret key
in a way that is more uh convenient to
to do calculations on
and using body maps yes and and the fact
it's short
so you do you think maybe maybe you can
think about it not necessarily as uh
unnecessarily is pre-processing question
of the
of the output of the prg right um
so you evaluate the whole prg and then
you compress it into these scenes
right uh i can't hear yeah yeah right
right that's true so the p you're saying
that pre-processing depends on
the description of g is that what you're
saying
sorry i couldn't hear you can you yes no
it's my on my end
oh i'm saying that um um so you are
saying pre-processing
depends on the output yeah yeah
yeah that's kind of kind of reminds me
of the xio that yell was talking about
and we're going to hear about also
tomorrow in the sense where you have
this notion of like
well we can look at the whole thing but
then we need to come up with
sort of a compact way of uh like a side
conversation that was just
with me so you are saying more accurate
term will be
calling it compress compressing i'm just
wondering because it seems like all of
these
all of these ideas are kind of uh sort
of
boiled down to similar compressor
outlines right but i think there's
something different here that the
compressed value is still secret right
it's not like the compressed value is
the public part
yeah it's always secret it's people to
compress
an output of a prg to something secret
the seed is always a compression
yeah so so here it really is about the
fact that
the decompressing algorithm becomes uh
so so in xio the compressed thing is
also a public thing it's the
it's the xio obfuscation right
right there it's public here at secret
semi secret
right so you're saying well it's you're
saying it doesn't even all the
compression doesn't even even need to be
public it's okay that there's
some part that remains secret but but
you make it simpler you
okay so right so here isn't there's
another
sort of uh axis of of improvement right
you
you make the function simpler by making
you know part of it public and
and leaving part of its secret yeah i
don't know yeah the fact that bilinear
map
is an obfuscation of degree to functions
itself so it gives you some
power that you can hide uh some sort of
secrets
with a restriction that you can only do
degree two computations on that
i think that it's it's there's a big
difference between having like
you know a plg which takes a uniform
speed applies say a degree two and a
half whatever and generates the output
versus the thing that you you know
you can generate through the random
strings but then you can kind of
generate syntax
a synthetic seed this is the thing that
you generate
such as based on this synthetic seed you
can evaluate a degree to enough
that's what allows you to bypass the
attack slide otherwise they are
its points would be valid right you
could apply the attacks by just fixing
the public park and
look at it as a degree to imputation
that's crucial
yeah that's crucial attacks didn't need
the
the attacks didn't need the seat to be
to be uniform in any way so
so so but the point the point is that
it's not it's not a degree to mapping
right i mean
when you think about the c there's no
uniform it means that you sample it by
using something which is not a degree
two
there's a higher degree thing that is in
there right no that still
the attacks would still have worked even
if the if you sample the
acid uh i mean i think it is kind of
crucial here that
uh
yes so it's not the same right
yeah the attack works as long as the
public seat and privacy they're
independently sampled it doesn't matter
what's their individual distribution
as long as they're independently sampled
you can always fix the public
seat so what we really rely on is that
they're correlated
that's yeah that's kind of crucial we're
going to see the the actual construction
of
yeah yeah yeah now if we start if we
stop
asking questions sure let's let's just
jump right into it
so what's the data well
i've told you what the public seat looks
like ais plus ci plus sigma
for sake of convenience i'm going to put
the um the coefficient vectors as a crs
like it's
known to everyone and now your goal is
to find a short seed which lets me
compute this way so i hope that that is
clear
now my point is that just because we are
encoding like um like this using lpn
errors
half the battle is already one remember
our prg is a prg in nc 0
so it's expressible as a low degree
degree d polynomial
over the reals right so
let's see what we can do so what i'm
going to do i'm going to first
pre-compute all the monomials in the
secret uh
of the lpn of degree d over 2
at most degree over 2 i'm going to
compute all the monomials and put it in
the private part of the scene
a reasonable question to ask is why can
you do that like
wouldn't it blow up the size well i'm
going to set the dimension
as was saying i'm going to set the
dimension of the secret small enough so
that it's not too much so
so the num the number of monomials will
be something like n
and a 2 is not a magic thing here you
should just want to make sure that
if you wanted to maybe you don't need
um if you wanted to you could make it d
yes you could have you'll just get
slightly worse parameters in the
final construction this is not where
uh d or d y d by 2 is crucial but let's
say uh
for the time being just let's do all the
monomials of degree d over 2.
now what you can do you can do that you
can do this so you can compute this
polynomial
g which is i told you it's a constant
degree polynomial over the real field
integer coefficients
so i can also evaluated mod p i'm going
to evaluate it at b minus a s
okay now why can i compute it in this
complexity model the degree 2.5
complexity model
because this is a degree d function
therefore its degree d in b
but b is public so that's fine it's
degree d in
a so a is public that's fine it's degree
d in s
but i have pre-processed all the
monomials of degree d over 2 in the
private sheet so it's degree 2 in
private seeds
so you can compute this now here is
the point the point is b minus a s is
just sigma plus
e okay c plus error mod b
right now just
see what essentially what are we doing
we are computing this prg on an input
uh which is sigma in most of the places
but
in a few places with like probability l
to the minus delta
i have some corruption of the error
because remember e is a lpn error
which is chosen so it's a sparse error
so we are computing it at approximately
the right input
and now you realize that prgg is
actually a constant locality prg
the num number of input bits that each
output is affected by is just a constant
so therefore i can compute that every
output bit is desired output
so for every given i index uh the
the computed output is actually equal to
the desired output g of sigma
that's at least 1 minus 1 by l to the
delta to the power locality
right that's just the straightforward
calculation using the probability of
error from lpn
this comes out to be pretty large one
minus order of l to the minus delta
so what does this say it says that any
individual
output is already correct with
probability
um 1 minus a small
fraction l to the minus delta and now
you can do
some more refined calculations
so you can i ask expectation turns out
that that's the expected of
number of bad output bits now bad output
bits are the output bits which are not
correct
which are not equal to my desired
computation this is something like m by
l to the delta
okay so uh a non-trivial fraction
of those are banned like just m by l to
the m
and then you can do of argument to show
that the size of the
bad set is lambda folds more than this
expected value is less than 1 by lambda
now what does it say it says that it's
only with
1 by lambda probability where lambda is
this parameter
i'm going to have more errors than
lambda m by l to the delta
but with very large probability of
probability of 1 minus 1 by lambda i'm
going to have
errors fewer than m lambda by l to the
alpha
okay so this means that for the rest of
uh the goal
what we can do just focus on correcting
m lambda by l to the delta errors
without uh
worrying about anything now there's a
tiny chance one lambda chance i will
have more errors in that
case we'll just give up and let uh
security amplification take care of
we'll lose some security and that's fine
we know how just to check if ei is zero
you will get an error right
or is that not for sure if e i uh
okay so look at each output bit see how
many it depends on some sigma i plus e i
now if all the errors the i is at zero
then you will get the right output if
there is one of them which is non-zero
um then you might get something else but
they might cancel out occasionally
occasionally but we can count on it and
share it very very tiny giants
okay okay so m lambda by l two zero i i
guess you could
could you not have relied on some more
independence here to actually say that
this probability that's
simple that's good question if you use a
random hypergraph
like in typical prgs you'll have a
random hyper graph
um i mean then you could
right then you could show in fact that
you can you rely on some better
concentration bounds and
that then you'll be good however we
don't want to make that restriction we
are working with arbitrary pr gene and
c0 so we don't know how the graph is
sampled
right can you anyway lose this lambda
from exactly
we all we will also anyway lose it with
one by lambda probability
uh as you was saying like the not all
hypergraphs are good
but uh then we can rely on combining
security or something else so
i mean essentially it's some loss
somewhere
but that's the only that's the only
reason why you don't get a negligible
security
new in your component so in principle if
you were willing to
assume some pseudo-randomness properties
of the hypergraph
then you would get negligible error
yes that is correct if you use a random
hypergraph you
uh you you get like better
bound here also we could resample the
seeds many many times
but that requires a very careful
analysis so i'm not going to talk about
that
there's a way to you could always apply
the random hyperlapse on your plg right
and now we target plg and make it robust
in this
sense i think say that again
you can always plug in this random
hypergraph over your plg
and argue that you don't lose security
it's not a new assumption
and you'll get some sort of robustness
from the original plg
i see let's plug it in wrap your plg
with this extra
layer of random hypergraph and the black
source or whatever
okay yeah that'll be interesting that
there are many solutions yeah yeah
but but say that uh but resampling will
definitely work you can sample the seed
manual
i will sure sure okay
let's just assume that this is fine for
the for now this goal of correcting i'm
lambda
by alternative alternatives okay so
what's the point or the one naive
approach is that
what what we want to do is the following
we define this correction vector which
is g
of sigma minus g of sigma plus c so this
is the desired computation minus the
the actual computation this is the error
vector now somehow what
i want to do roughly here the high level
goal i want to put
it in the private part of the seat
somehow and then compute this y prime
as just the computed value plus the
correction so i'm just
literally correcting the offset
uh but the point is we cannot just
trivially do it right uh
this correction vector is too big the
dimension of this is m
uh so all the stretch will be killed so
the point is that we need to
somehow make use of of the fact that
this correction vector is sparse
remember the correction vector has m
lambda by l to the delta entries
you got to make use of the fact but we
cannot just
use it directly one naive way of using
the fact that correction vector is
sparse
is by only putting the non-zero values
in the private part of the seat
that would have worked we could have
guaranteed expansion because
this is non-zero only at m lambda l to
the delta
points but then the only way we know how
to use this fact is like by using
by revealing the indices of bad output
bits like the output bits which need
correction
and then at least we don't we could not
figure out a way in which
uh you'll not hurt security so revealing
the set of
bad output bits is actually very like it
hurts
lpn security because you'll eventually
leak which of the lpn
samples have errors in them there is
also like i usually
and another thing you could potentially
do which is to also put the indexes of
the
of these points as part of the private
seat that also would not cost much but
it would be a high degree computer it
will be a high degree computation
exactly so
we couldn't figure out a way of making
use of these ideas
so what is the high level picture then
what are we going to do in order to get
around it roughly how our solution looks
like is the following
we're going to take this correction
vector and observe it's as really sparse
vector
we're going to encode it in a matrix in
a big matrix
but this matrix is going to be sparse
and then we'll
every sparse matrix like various parts
matrix have low rank
we'll use matrix factorization to
compress it that's all we are going to
do
so let's see this uh with an example
let's say you have one error so let's
say the correction vector just has one
nonzero
entry and let's see how you can make
this work so remember
we have m output bits so i can make a
matrix of size root m cross root m
that's the dimension this matrix has m
entries
then i let's say i pick any obvious
bijection
uh which makes which maps the output
bits of the prg into this grid
that's this is some obvious bi-direction
like you could
uh i'm not specifying how to sample this
so what's the point we'll take the
correction vector remember it is one
sparse
and then i'm going to map it using this
bijection into this grid so
m of phi i is correction of i okay let's
just
put it here now i observe this is a rank
one matrix
i can factor it as u times v where
dimension of u and v
is root m so this just because it's rank
one and the width of the matrix is root
m
uh now it's straightforward i'm going to
put this u and v in the private part of
the seed
and i'm going to put this index fine so
that it's publicly known
uh then i'm going to compute uh the
following g of i
sigma plus c that that was what i was
already computing
plus uh i'm going to construct this
correction matrix
uh reconstructed by multiplying u with v
so it's a degree two computation and
that's legit because we could handle
degree to computation in the secret part
of the seed
so i compute this and i eval query it at
the correct location where i know that
the correction
for i-8 and presets that can be
that is known using this function phi
okay so essentially this is gi of sigma
plus e plus correction which is the
right value
okay so this is is good it will correct
me the right value
what happens to the stretch size of
the c diff we want to show that the size
of the public pile of the seed plus
secret part of the seed that's small
so how small they are they are n log p
for the
lpn samples the number of monomials were
also in log p
uh plus addition have we have is the
size of u and v
but remember u and v is of dimension
root m so i'm go i'm going to get two
time log p here
and this is much less than the number of
output bits m
right so we are good here so this is
good and the security device we also
find because
phi this function does not reveal any
bad indices right it's
just a computation which is oblivious of
the bad set
so that's fine okay so the takeaway from
this is that this will correct one error
and in fact if you were to generalize
this idea it will correct
say m to the point four nine errors
that's all that the most you can do
uh because in that case we'll get m to
the point nine nine nine dependency here
um however note that we are not our goal
is not to correct m to the point four
nine errors we wanted to correct
m lambda by n to these entire hours this
could be potentially much more than m to
the point four nine
so that's our goal so what do we do
turns out that this idea doesn't work
but this very simple extension of
this idea works and the idea is really
simple
remember we had m lambda l to the delta
errors instead of having
one giant bucket of size root m cross
root m let
why don't i just have t small buckets
so t was the number of errors i i
have t small matrices each matrix is of
dimension l to the delta over 2 times l
to the delta over 2.
so i'm carefully choosing the dimension
so that the total number of entries in
each matrix is l to the delta
and the total number of entries in all
the matrix combined is m lambda
so that's much more than m uh what this
lets me do
this time i'm going to sam i'll do the
same thing i'm going to sample
two random maps or rather assignment
function what they do
they take m output bits of the prg and
randomly place them into these bins
okay so this is an in some injective
mapping which is randomly chosen
uh this the fact that it's randomly
chosen will show up later it's
somewhat important for calculation so
uh we're going to sample this maps and
for convenience just think of this
maps as being two functions there's a
five bucket which will tell me
what matrix each output index goes to
then there is five index which tells me
which of
uh the index in that bucket
does does that output bit
maps too it will just assign the index
in the matrix
so this is just for convenience uh and
then do the same thing
take the correction vector i remember if
you remember it has t
entries non-zero and these three entries
will show in these matrix like
randomly dispersed okay
so once i have assigned them
i want you to observe that the number of
buckets we chose was t
which is exactly equal to the number of
um error
locations so
i can't hear you boys
hello does anyone just
so basically what you're doing is m over
t boys we couldn't hear you so
so okay okay so so i'll i'll let you
uh continue and then no no no now now we
can hear you can you say that again
so i was asking basically if i
understand correctly you're taking the
output vector which is of length m and
you are black
breaking it into t blocks and each one
of them
is you're thinking of now a matrix which
is square root m by square root
by square root and by square root t and
for each one of those matrices you're
doing exactly what you did before
exactly that's exactly right so so
roughly speaking you are going to
somehow save something that looks like a
square root of the dimension
in a factor of something like square
root of the dimension
that's that's exactly where you're going
to save l to the delta over 2 yes that's
precise
okay so uh this was 10 steps ahead but
let me tell you
where i am so so now we have dispersed
this correction vector
into these matrices now observe the
number of buckets i chose
was exactly t the number of errors was
also exactly t
so in expectation every bucket will get
at most one entry
uh by doing more refined calculation
every bucket will
just the fact that the function is phi
is random
every bucket will get at most lambda
entries you can show this
with probability very high 1 minus order
of
e to the minus lambda so once you have
that
which means every matrix is ranked less
than lambda every matrix has
a rank less than lambda i can do the
same thing i will factor all of these
matrices ui
mi as ui times vi where the dimension
will be
root l to the delta times lambda
okay and then i'm going to do exactly
the same thing i'm going to instead of
having one matrix u and v i'm going to
put t matrices
capital t matrices ui times u i and v i
in the private part of the seed
and i'll put the phi function in the
index and then
same thing gi of sigma plus error
um and then i'm going so i know that the
error for ith
entry sits in matrix phi
bucket um of i that's where the
matrix is and the location is phi index
of i so i'm going to
compute gi of sigma plus e plus u
the corresponding u times corresponding
v and query it at index phi
index i and then i know that this is gi
of sigma plus c plus correction which is
the right value
so um why did we need the uv
decomposition is it easy to see
why did i use uv uh thing
yeah that's exactly because we want
compression and we could not put the
matrix m here
but if i factor them and they're low
ranked matrices i'll get compression
and also because degree matrix
multiplication is a degree to operation
right so
yeah that's right it fits yeah and
maybe one kind of a general takeaway
which maybe people knew but maybe people
didn't know is it
could be the following right if you're
trying to encode
suppose we ignore a logarithmic term so
if you're trying to ign
encode a space uh a t-space vector in
m in m dimensions then information
theoretically
you can do it in with only t
t beats let's ignore like the log piece
part so
information theoretically you cannot do
it with t bits uh if you do
if you insisted on linear uh maybe you
have to use
m bits but with degree two you can do i
guess the geometric average of them is
square root t
m so you can maybe not get all the way
to the information theoretic but you can
get
to much better than him
that's that seems right uh maybe i'll
take this offline to just
understand the formal parameters what
you're saying
okay so um uh
right so this is where we were this is
good we can correct up till the t errors
and the security wise we are fine
more crucial thing is what happens to
the stretch if you look at the
private part of the c that's n log p so
that's fine this the
number of monomials was also n log p
that's fine the new addition is this
ui and vi so how many matrices are there
there are capital t of them
what the size of each individual ui
matrix
that's um that's the
as we saw um it's lambda times
l to the delta over 2 and then
capital t was m lambda by l to the delta
so when you
compute this product it becomes m lambda
squared by l to the l over 2
and this this is the tiny amount of
saving
that we are getting getting l to the
delta over 2 that is what saves us
just a little amount of savings like l
to the delta over 2 in the denominator
i think this is what was also referring
right
yeah so basically i think the square
root of the dimension
yes you you i think that the length
would be
the geometric average of t and m so
ignoring the lambda thing so if if you
think of t as
m divided by something then the
geometric average is
m divided by the square root of this for
something
yeah okay yeah this is exactly what this
is
okay so l to the delta over two and this
is just tiny amount of savings turns out
that's enough for
um getting what you want so this
sure yeah like maybe it's a silly one
but but
this whole maneuver that you're doing
that this is this is very elegant but i
wonder
what are we trying to solve like uh
right i mean you had the plg
with some noise right the noisy version
of your prg
is this bad like you're trying to
collect these cells is it because of
security or because of correctness
what is the problem because i
like okay maybe i'll let you answer and
then i'll say what what
no no okay can you repeat your question
i'm not following very well
you were leaking maybe benny is asking
suppose you were
uh leaking the error
error to prg suppose you were uh to
just not worry about core eye and
collecting
leakage for example say that i'm kind of
i'm kind of building my plg you know i
have some arrows and then i do
extraction for example over it right i
mean make sure that things would still
be
a pseudo-random if to even after the
arrows and i still get my stretch you
know nicely
but how do you do extraction degree two
uh i mean
uh and you also like you also want the
outputs to basketball
publicly enough functions you have some
some noise
you also want the outputs to be small so
that you can do discrete log and
and and take it like you also want uh
bounded outputs
do you want to remain like a zero one
thing okay
small it doesn't have to be zero one but
something small good good
yeah it also might be of an issue that
the thing do you
run the linear function over would be uh
something that is large and you don't
uh and that also could be a problem for
you that
you cannot treat this thing that you're
going to do extraction over
and do a linear okay maybe that's
actually okay maybe that's not true
maybe that's not true yes
yeah at the end of the day you want
small outputs and i don't know how to
extract from general field elements in a
low degree manner like degree two
i don't know how to do that so the
conclusion was this was required for
um to compute it other than for security
right to
efficiency rather than they're related
actually
correct computation and security they're
related to each other
if you're not correct then you are
losing security you won't
know how to argue right
no but i i it seemed you're talking
about efficiency that you want to
get the discrete log and that's why you
want the outputs to be small rather than
i mean that that seemed like the main
motivation for collecting these errors
rather than
a secret yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah when i
meant correctness i meant some some
other characters but yeah you are
you're right about that so so there will
be an amplification step later you're
saying
yeah there will be security
amplification which which will roughly
describe
and uh that's fairly technical
unfortunately it can't cover and
we could not okay sounds good okay so
uh proof i'm not going to spend time on
it because it's a really simple proof
um yeah if you are if you have uh lpn
samples encrypting sigma and vr prg and
sigma then we know
that the output looks random and omit
described it so i won't spend time on it
now how do you there's one caveat which
i didn't tell you we are going to lose
one by lambda and security why
because of the markov argument we did uh
we had a
loss of probability one by lambda
therefore we manage only to get
a weekly secure sprg and then this
picture will take you through uh
to the wire to io and it rebuilds on
lots of ideas
developed by the community over a few
years um and rachel
stock is an excellent reference to see
that
okay managed to get
uh not weak sprg you would still get
weak in the next uh
next transformation right because when
you you like add small smudging noise so
you still get
uh you still get good uh negligible
security for the fe right
we we do get uh negligible security uh
like that depends on the proof strategy
so i'm saying you would still need to do
even if you managed to get the sbrg
with negligible security you would still
need to do amplification because you get
like the weak cut there are two reasons
you get weak right one is
that the sprg is weak security and the
other is that you add small smudging
noise
so if you have small smudging turns out
uh there are schemes
uh at least there is an approach in
order to get
like use leakage amplification a leakage
simulation from
uh jp um 13 and like do you know
computational leakage simulation
like uh you could use that and you can
get a proof
which which has a negligible security
loss i i can tell you offline about it
so it's just
uh if you smudge with a polynomial
amount that doesn't mean that this
all the security is lost i mean you can
still argue negligible security
this is just a different proof
you are saying uh it's basically a
stricter analysis or it's a different
technique altogether
it's you're going to use adversary
dependent proof strategies
so if you know this leakage
amplification
um by uh the first one first paper was
jp13
christoph and dimitar were the authors
so you could i could
i can you can ask me offline i'll be
happy to tell you
all right so uh so this basically also
explains your comment
about boaz uh question that if you had a
good enough
prg here which gave you the one by two
path lambda then you could have
directly got it without doing the
amplification
yeah that that's that's exactly right
i mean depends on which path you take
there's a path where you
you still need to do amplify again but
it's not something holy
you can always come up with a different
bootstrapping
okay so finally i won't spare like this
is the last slide
just leave you at a note of open
questions so tomorrow you're going to
hear really interesting talks on um an
approach on how to construct two will be
secure post quantum
io uh unfortunately they are not on
well-founded assumptions but they are
considerably simpler
from the previous assumptions so i'll
encourage all of you to look at that
another question is the efficiency
question if
if you can come up with something
efficient implementable even from
non-well-founded but simple assumptions
that will be a game changer so it's
really
exciting uh finally the last question is
can you
construct io from other assumptions not
just like what we are using but there
are many many assumptions out there
doesn't have to be post quantum is there
any other approach that's what
an open question then with that i'll
leave the floor open to questions and
thank you for listening
ayush uh about that post quantum
security could you say
a few words on where exactly it it fails
to be postponed
wait hold on can we uh thank you
thank you thank you thank you everyone
thanks
so amit i can ask you a question i can
answer your question offline if you
show me
yes so um maybe we can uh
people that want to stretch out they can
stretch out otherwise
you can also move to gather and we can
discuss more
and we'll only have a half hour break uh
rather than a i'm guessing many of
people are
this is not their lunch time anyway so
it doesn't really matter and of course
you can always eat next to
uh it's dinner time
so you can bring your dinner uh to uh
to the computer the this is not like a
usual lecture hall so we'll see you in a
half an hour for benny's talk